hey let's go bros my name is peter pan
today we're going to teach you how no
you're not gonna get taught [ __ ] my ban
I'm sorry
today we're gonna realize if ha Family
Guy it's highly suggested by you bros
I'm interested to see what the hell
we're gonna get out of this so let's do
dias
I can tell this is gonna be good you
know what they say about a man who has
balls this chintz it will hurt if you
kick them in the face okay I found a
really good stock image hahaha it
already kind of looks like him perfect
let's crop that [ __ ] out okay let's
start off with the glasses I realize I
have the same glasses kind of
[Music]
that looks fantastic what the [ __ ] no I
forgot to make a new layer that looks so
good this is how you do pro photo shops
[Music]
okay let's add the pupils looks pretty
good he's looking straight at my nipples
and I really like it
please continue let's fix his nose it's
more of a [ __ ] potato I guess
[Music]
yeah
so sexy
what a suck amazing nose next step is
Zee mouth where are we going to make him
smile a bit mo see it looks happy
yeah yeah that perv smile yeah
[Music]
now this is the face of a man who gets a
lot of [ __ ] so I guess he doesn't have
a chin here it's this one continuous
force of reckoning so I I don't I don't
know how to
[Music]
[Applause]
it is time for the moment you've all
been waiting or the insertion of the
balls let's get this done how I I really
don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
I [ __ ] done it the balls the balls
the buzz breasted boots he needs hair
obviously somehow so let's let's do that
looks almost real
there you have it what do you guys think
I love them both so much
yeah feel free to quote me on that the
balls really did hit the spot Nick
I forgot the ears but I can't be
bothered so let's move on to the next
family manatee murder of the Griffin
Griffin okay mmm we did Peter obviously
next we need to do Stewie I'm excited
because this is gonna be good you just
know you just [ __ ] know
all right let's let's do this there
here's our baby now we need to make his
[ __ ] face look like an American
football done
[Music]
that looks perfect yes
Styria what the [ __ ] man what happened
let's add that triangle nose
[Music]
hey that looks pretty good I'm happy
with it
now for the man I can hardly tell them
apart hope I cut demon baby right there
[Music]
this looks like Stewie Griffin highest
[ __ ] I don't know why that's funny okay
and there's something we missed the hair
I guess
[Music]
Stewie it looks so nice yes the angry
eyebrows weenie I guess we need to add
those let's steal from this little [ __ ]
[Music]
I wonder if there's anything we can do
about the eyes not looking like he's
smoked the biggest fat is join ever all
right let's see if we can [ __ ] with it
[Music]
there oh my god I can't believe what I
finished it I don't really capture his
soul like his angry expression been
buggin finger me drug addict my virgin
eyes that made me want to delete my
account all right well I'm glad to
present the work I do for you thank you
and leap for leaving a like and I will
see you in the next real life suggest me
what you want to see become a real life
a fad and I'll see brother next one
thanks for watching it's always stay
awesome for us
look so real I mean I don't really have
to do much
[Music]